- [Narrator] Amami Ōshima is an island
off the coast of mainland Japan.
And while it's well-known
for its thriving coral
reefs and sandy beaches,
it's sumo that puts
this island on the map.
Amami Ōshima takes great
pride in raising young boys
to become some of the
country's best wrestlers.
- [Jiro] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] With over
150 dohyōs, or sumo rings,
Amami Ōshima has the highest concentration
of sumo facilities in Japan,
making the sport accessible
to most young people on the island.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Jiro] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] But sumo
is not only practiced
as a means for future success;
it's a nod to the island's history
and has been embedded in its
culture for hundreds of years.
Annual festivals include sumo tournaments
where wrestlers come out to participate.
- [Jiro] (speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] But despite
the island's efforts
to maintain sumo as a cultural staple,
the sport has begun to
decrease in popularity
among young people.
- (speaking in foreign language)